[Música]
es una de las canciones de Rock más
famosas e inusuales que dominó las
listas de éxitos y vendió millones de
copias pero la bohemian rhapsody que
muchos conocemos y amamos hoy podría
haber sido muy diferente en un aspecto
un borrador de la canción escrito por
Freddie Mercury sugiere que una vez
estuvo en juego la idea de otro título
tachado pero aún legible en la parte
superior derecha del borrador hay un
garabato que dice mongolian rhapsody el
borrador es solo una de las más de 1000
pertenencias de Mercury que son de
visacará subasta en septiembre en nombre
de su vieja amiga Mary Austin so the
beach prevé que se venda por entre un
millón y uno coma tres millones de
dólares
otros de los objetos subastados son el
catsut de satén Marfil que apareció en
el video musical de la canción en 1975
cuyo valor se estima entre 62.000 y 87
mil dólares
también se subastará lo que se cree que
es el primer cuaderno de las letras de
Mercury que contiene versos del éxito